[Musique]
je dis bonjour bonjour vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle thinker view on voudrait avoir
votre avis sur ce qui se passe en ce
moment le numérique et toutes ces
petites affaires qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire tout se passe bien
ça travaille pas trop en tout cas c'est
mon job intéressé au numérique au global
vous avez vu je suis au sein de ce
gouvernement rattaché au premier
ministre c'est un numérique où je
m'occupe d'un peu tous les sujets c'est
la transformation numérique du monde
celle de l'économie celle de l'état les
questions de cybersécurité est question
de l'inclusion numérique bon bah sur ces
quatre sujets là ya des choses qui vont
très bien les choses qui vont moins bien
et donc il ya des priorités sur
l'inclusion ça va pas bien il faut qu'on
aille plus loin et qu'on aille plus vite
pour les 13 millions de français qui
l'utilisent pas le numérique sur la
cybersécurité voix ya plusieurs sujets
il ya des différents niveaux de
protection aujourd'hui on a un sujet sur
les pme et tpe pme où il faut vraiment
qu'on s'investisse et ça a été une des
priorités là pour le mois de la cyber
qui vient de s'écouler sur la question
économique sur les start up on est
plutôt pas mal on est un des meilleur
écosystème en europe parmi les meilleurs
écosystèmes monde se développe je
continue la gym priorité c'est la
diversité
on a un sujet sur par contre la
transformation de mecs des tpe pme là on
n'est pas beau là il faut absolument
qu'on se mobilise donc là on a un plan
qu'ils encourent on mobilise des acteurs
mais on est très en retard nos tpe pme
aujourd'hui elles sont 16e en europe sur
l'utilisation du numérique pour leurs
modèles d'affaires puis après il ya le
sujet sur la transformation de l'état on
va la france elle a des super services
certain super service qui fonctionne
bien qui sont très utilisés mais
globalement il faut qu'on arrive à créer
une une fluidité et une intelligence
plus globale de cet état numérique qui
doit créer plus de valeur pour les gens
et qui doit être plus intelligent dans
l'utilisation des ressources combien
vous gagnez pour tous à vous parler de
mon salaire il est complètement public
je pourrais pas vous dire le chiffre
exact il est rentré série doit être
autour de 7500 5800 euros autres comme
ça mais le net net les avantages en
nature
l'avantagé en nature les avantages en
qui sont des désavantages en nature qui
sont d'être toujours protégé ce
pénible comment ils disponibles mois est
toujours disponible et donc du coup ce
qui me protège aussi et donc je suis
protégé suivi
je passais un avantage en nature vous
parlez de protection
quelles sont nos rapports à l'heure
actuelle après les fuites de l'année
celle d'edward snowdon
alors question est quelles sont nos
rapports avec les états unis après les
chutes des dents snowdon bon notre
rapport avec les états unis c'est quand
même un rapport de fraternité c'est un
rapport c'est un état avec lequel on
partage beaucoup c'est un état avec
lequel la question de sécurité du monde
et est un sujet essentiel c'est un état
avec lequel on a différents lieux de la
du partenariat il ya l'otan il ya l'onu
et aussi les relations bilatérales qu'on
peut avoir avec eux donc la relation
avec un partenaire il est toujours
exigeante et toujours de toujours
remettre en jeu l'amitié l'amour qu'on a
avec un état partenaire toujours c'est
il faut jamais le prendre pour acquis
jamais par contre il faut aussi être
certains de dire qu'il ya des états avec
lesquels on a des relations fortes et
que ça ça participe à une stabilité dans
le monde donc c'est une amitié forte
engagée mais pas naïve qu'est ce que
vous entendez par pas naïfs c'est à dire
que c'est ce que je vous disais dans
tous les relations qu'on a on est très
exigeants l'un avec l'autre mais c'est
pâques avec les états unis c'est dans le
cadre de toutes les relations qu'on peut
avoir au sein de l'union c'est différent
au sein de l'union européenne seule
l'union européenne on a fait un pas en
plus avec chacun des états on a fait un
pas en plus avec le partage globale de
l'information partage des capacités
partage de beaucoup d'autres actions à
suivre je parle en général de notre
capacité à agir dans le monde on a
décidé avec cela d'être une véritable
unité avec les pays qui font pas partie
l'union européenne c'est pas pareil
serre que ça reste un état étranger avec
lequel on a une fraternité forte avec
lequel on a une coopération forte mais
qui doit passer par toujours plus de
transparence plus des changes plus
d'évaluation
est ce que vous pensez que les états
unis ont utilisé les dates 1 française
pour
entraîner leur intelligence artificielle
la grande question dans ce monde qui se
transforme c'est qu'on nous dit les
états unis c'est quoi et est ce que il
ya des opérateurs privés qui opèrent en
france qui opère partout dans le monde
qui utilisent ces données pour
augmenter la capacité de leurs outils à
être plus intelligente oui ils l'ont
fait que le consentement des
utilisateurs
tine options c'est ça aux petits
notables et privé c'est schild est plein
de questions qui font qu'aujourd'hui on
a souhaité que des services européens
puissent vendre aux états unis et que
des services américains puissent vendre
en europe et que ça se passe de façon
facilité avec des garde-fous des deux
côtés mais on a souhaité aujourd'hui et
là où vous avez raison ce serait pareil
si schild par exemple elle vient d'avoir
une évaluation première évaluation par
la commission de de l'état de la
relation sur le privé si celle bon ben
on a redonné aux exigences européennes
sur bien mettre en place les différents
garde-fous nommer un ombudsman définitif
être transparent sur la relation avec
les agences être transparent sur le
contrôle et la sécurité apportée à ces
données ça c'est les éléments de cette
relation qu'on veut forte mais mais
exigeante est-ce que vous pensez que les
gars façon la pointe de diamant des
services de renseignement américains
c'est pas ma certitude et quand vous
regardez aujourd'hui les discussions que
peuvent avoir ces mêmes acteurs avec
leur propre service
vous voyez que la situation est
nécessairement plus complexe que celle
là aujourd'hui vous
aujourd'hui on doit se dire que sega
femmes ont un rôle particulier et pas
que sega fin parlons des grands
opérateurs numériques systémique surtout
ceux qui opèrent plusieurs millions de
dhs adresse mail quand on le perd 300
millions d'adressés mails en europe on a
une responsabilité particulière à la
fois sur la sécurité à la fois dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme mais aussi
dans la protection des données
personnelles est dans le fait de créer
un internet libre de créer un internet
qui permet à chacun de s'exprimer de
vendre de communiquer et d'avoir une vie
saine alors une question de notre
communauté est ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre le projet indect il faut
gourmandise et plus sur ce projet alors
de souvenirs le projet indect c'est une
surveillance globale pour la protection
des citoyens européens c'est-à-dire
l'interconnexion de certaines bases de
données pour pouvoir un petit peu ce qui
se passe en chine vous n'avez pas vu
cette
ce tweet de bourdin qui montrait
intervention de bourdin direct
intervention sur la chine sur ces
presque une carotte si vous respectez
le standard chinois un texte c'est
l'interconnexion
de certains fichiers pour la
reconnaissance faciale des plaques
d'immatriculation et la crainte des
internautes se serait l'éradication de
la vie privée bon je vais pas vous
répondre d'actes je sais pas exactement
la teneur du dispositif est ce que c'est
un dispositif extrêmement concentré
certains fichiers de police et dans ce
cas là ça fait ça fait plusieurs
dizaines décennies qu'on travaille avec
cette volonté d'avoir créé interpol dans
la capacité à partager l'information
qu'à passer de la partager de capacités
opérationnelles pour lutter contre le
crime organisé pour lutter contre
terrible dans ces cas là c'est important
de pouvoir faire des choses
si vous me posez la question de la
surveillance généralisée du partage
massif d'information du croisement des
informations de sécurité avec des
informations personnelles voire des
informations commerciales
ce qu'on entende se raconter aujourd'hui
sur ce projet chinois c'est quand même
le mélange de l'information de réseaux
sociaux mélangé à des informations
commerciales issues de sites d'e
commerce avec des informations de
sécurité qui viennent des opérateurs
régalien de l'état et avec les
opérateurs civils de l'étape qui
normalement ne sont pas à partager leurs
informations avec les entités
commerciales si vous demandez si je
trouve bien qu on mélange tout ça
ensemble la réponse est non
ça a le mérite d'être clair
le projet chinois de
standardiser les comportements par de
l'intelligence artificielle par tous ces
canaux de surveillance qu'est ce que
vous en pensez alors encore une serre va
débarquer chez nous une chose que je
veux nuancé sur ce que j'ai c'est que je
ne connais pas l'état d'avancée réaliste
de réelles de ce projet chinois je sais
ce qu'ils en aient dit donc denses qui
en ai dit je peux que dire que c'est pas
bon soit pour la france précieux pour
l'europe j'ai pas envie qu'on normalise
les comportements des gens les gens ils
ont pas être normalisé par contre faut
favoriser des comportements
des comportements positifs
dans l'éducation par l'éducation par le
modèle par le fait que moi j'ai envie
qu'à l'école on participe à plus parler
de solidarité de création de commun j'ai
envie que dans l'enseignement supérieur
on arrive à se donner tous cette
philosophie c'est dynamique d'être utile
aux autres quel que soit le métier qu'on
fait que dans l'entrepreneuriat à la
française il ya cette idée d'être à la
fois performant et de re mesurer son
impact social environnemental toutes ces
questions là qui font qu'à la fin on vit
mieux ensemble si on les pratique tous
sur les transitions environnementales
soient transition numérique ya plein de
choses qui dans nos comportements
collectifs permettront de faire mieux
mais dans ce qui est du sud eu que du
côté de la morale je prouve que ce n'est
pas le rôle de l'état de normaliser la
morale de co2 ce site web alors on va
parler d'intelligence artificielle et
des valeurs
de lentilles l'intelligence artificielle
est un outil et les valeurs qu'on
utilise pour utiliser cet outil vous les
voyez comment en tout cas vous posez la
question d'un corps comme on doit la
poser comme la france la pose
aujourd'hui c'est l'intelligence
artificielle ce n'est pas juste une
quête technologique où on devrait dire
fois que le plus rapide faut être poli
le plus vite possible faut absolument
qu'on soit les premiers et qu'on se pose
pas la question de pourquoi au fait et
quelles sont les conséquences
aujourd'hui la mission qu'on a lancé
avec cédric villani elle a pour but pas
d'apporter toutes les réponses mais
poser toutes les questions qu'ils dire
aujourd'hui c'est quoi notre souhait
nous les hommes nous les citoyens pour
l'intelligence artificielle qu'est ce
qu'on a envie qu'elle apporte à la
société et une fois qu'on sait ce
qu'elle veut qu'elle apporte à la
société comment se mobilisent pour avant
les capacités de recherche par les
capacités technologiques pour le faire
mais aussi les capacités humaines et
capacités sociales de s'organiser pour
l'accueillir ce que je racontais au
sénat ya quelques jours c'est qu'est ce
qu'on fait si on se dit que
l'intelligence artificielle doit
participer à plus de sécurité qu'est-ce
qu'on fait du robot autonome
policier dubaïote qu'est-ce qu'on fait
des robots autonomes de l'armée tuant
actuaires et non tueur ya les deux
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des agrumes des
décisions vous avez vu aujourd'hui on a
parlé de la fin d'apb anciennes versions
un nouvel abbé
dans cinq ans dans dix ans à quoi ça
ressemble l'orientation scolaire à quoi
ça ressemble l'affectation dans
l'enseignement supérieur qu'est ce qui
est de l'ordre de la décision qu est ce
qui est de l'ordre de l'algorithme
aujourd'hui ce qui est annoncé par le
premier ministre et par la misère
seulement supérieur c'est des règles de
dire on veut que les étudiants puissent
choisir leur formation mais que pour la
choisir y ait des règles de l'autre côté
et que à la fin on arrive à trouver les
bonnes places pour les bonnes personnes
au bon endroit et ça c'est les humains
qui décide puis après si on veut être
assisté d'un algorithme intelligent
voire un algorithmes d'intelligence
artificielle pour participer à aider à
cette affectation pourquoi pas mais pour
le faire il faut d'abord avoir décidé
les règles est-ce que vous intéresser
aux règles chinoises au niveau de
l'intelligence artificielle est ce qu'on
appelle les règles chinoises lui le ce
qu'on appelle le rêve final au rêve le
rêve chinois le rêve chinois de rayonner
de récupérer son son rang perdues donc
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
perception chinoise autour de
l'intelligence artificielle dans un
contexte de guerre économique et j'en
profite pour dédicacer cette vidéo à
robert guillaumont feu robert gibbs
ces votes c'est votre tour
c'est alors sur cette question intéresse
artificielle et de la conquête ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure sur il faut
savoir vers où on va il ya une
compétition on a plusieurs continents
plusieurs pays qui ont la capacité à
investir beaucoup
pour aller le plus vite possible mais la
question c'est aller le plus vite vers
quoi la question c'est d'investir
beaucoup dans quoi mais il se trouve
qu'on a investi depuis plus de cent ans
dans l'intelligence des citoyens et plus
de cent ans on a un système éducatif
gratuit c'est plutôt en tapant d'un
système d'enseignement supérieur et de
recherche qui est parmi les plus
performants au monde le quotient
intellectuel français mais ce
jeu je vous maîtrise pas ses chiffres là
mais globalement
je ne pense pas et les chiffres montrent
que le niveau de nos chercheurs ou le
niveau de la recherche française baisse
est ce que tous les français doivent
consacrer encore plus de temps aux
intelligences je serai toujours pour est
ce qu'on va faire plus de pédagogie des
sciences tout au long de la vie je suis
pour est ce qu'on va faire plus de
pédagogie du numérique tout au long d'un
vie je suis pour et d'ailleurs nous
gouvernement est tellement pur qu'on a
décidé de mobiliser les 15 milliards
d'euros du plan compétences dans
commence assure qu'en permanence les
français notamment ceux qui sont qu'ils
vont être le plus éloignés dès nouvelles
formes de travail puisse mettre à jour
leurs compétences notamment sur les
sujets de transition numérique
transition environnementale
revenons à la chine comment la chimie
opère sous les choses donc encore une
fois vous savez quand on est membre d'un
gouvernement il faut toujours être très
réservé dans l'analyse et le jugement
qu'on peut porter sur un autre
gouvernement parce que on peut ne pas
être d'accord avec les choix faits par
un autre gouvernement mais à un moment
sur certaines situations on est des
partenaires présentent maintenir la paix
dans le monde c'est un choix c'est une
volonté et on doit garder des relations
avec tout mon sur tous ces sujets comme
disait le général de gaulle ou comme
faisait le général de gaulle avec qui
êtes-vous prêt vous fâcher et oussalah
france elle a toujours tenu ses
positions partout dans le monde et
depuis toujours c'est à dire qu'on est
prêt à se fâcher avec tout le monde sauf
qu'on a aussi une responsabilité absolue
c'est qu'on ne fait partie des membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité ont
fait partie des leaders de la diplomatie
et dans le monde notamment pour
maintenir la paix et cette diplomatie
elle tient aussi un ingrédient qui est
de garder des relations positives avec
tous les pays être capable de
toujours discuter avec chacun tout en
étant très exigeant tout en disant ce
sur quoi on n'est pas d'accord tout en
dénonçant certaines et certains
comportements mais sur intelligence
artificielle et la stratégie chinoise là
c'est pas une question de jeu juge le
gouvernement chinois au passé
aujourd'hui ils ont décidé massivement
investir pour aller très vite nous
l'europe mais aussi décidé que c'était
très important et on a investi à hauteur
de nos capacités d'investissement mais
aujourd'hui en europe la question c'est
plutôt vers quoi on veut aller sur les
transitions environnementale et et
numérique et la convergence de ces
transitions le sujet du transport ça
c'est un vrai sujet de transformation
massive aujourd'hui
faut qu'on se rendre compte si on
transforme les modes de déplacements en
france et en europe on peut très
largement impacter notre pacte
environnemental en moins de dix ans si
dans dix ans on arrive à des systèmes de
déplacements intelligents multimodaux
personnalisés basés sur des véhicules
des véhicules automatisés des véhicules
électriques à notre empreinte je peux
vous assurer elle a un impact très fort
sur sur la sueur sur l'environnement
pour la planète donc il ya des
changements que votre père et
intelligence artificielle et sur
laquelle on doit dire peut-être que
c'est sur ça que nous l'europe on veut
investir massivement vous parler
d'environnement est ce que le numérique
consomme énormément est ce que le
numérique utilisent des terres rares est
ce que notre empreinte énergétique notre
empreinte écologique est plutôt local où
est perçu comme locales alors que si je
vais exploiter les terreur en corée du
nord ou si je vais exploiter le cuivre
au chili
ou si je vais faire recycler mes
batteries en inde qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous avez raison ça le sujet de
la dette environnementale dallaire tout
objet numérique c'est là que c'est le
président de l'ademe qui a fait cette
remarque à deux jours quand j'étais avec
lui vous voyez ce téléphone il pèse
quelques dizaines de grammes que
centaines de grammes pourtant il a une
bête environnementale de près de 80 kg
90 kilos 800 tonnes selon la complexité
et les terres qui sont à l'intérieur
vous avez parlé de terra pour extraire
des terrains on mobilise une énergie
très importante mais avant de répond
plus longuement sur cette question qui
est importante je vais vraiment qu'on ne
caricature pas le numérique comme étant
un
pourvoyeur ou un
[Musique]
ennemi de l'environnement parce que
d'abord le numérique permet aussi de
mieux utiliser les ressources permet de
mobiliser moins de ressources pour
arriver à la même valeur à la fin permet
de mobiliser moins 2 par exemple une
déplacement optimisé grâce à
l'intelligence numérique grâce aux
outils numériques permettent de faire
moins de déplacements moins de
mobilisation des énergies carbone pour
déplacer un objet à d'un objet d une
personne un point a à un point b et le
numérique qui permet dans les
organisations d'optimiser les flux et le
organisations d'optimiser l'utilisation
du des énergies donc le mien qui
participe beaucoup à l'économie à
la responsabilité environnementale mais
ensuite le 2 mai qui doit lui aussi être
responsable environnementalement et par
exemple si on prend un exemple celui du
bitcoin et vous avez là les discussions
qui a aujourd'hui sur le bitcoin est sur
les nouveaux modèles alternatifs dont on
connaît pas encore la la la la force
mais je fiabilité ou la fiabilité oui
tout comme on s'est posé la question sur
lui connaît aussi imposant corps et sur
la s ur la blogging en général et
le modèle blog shane généralisée à tous
les usages de la vie pose un problème
environnemental pose un problème
d'utilisation des ressources dont il
faut se poser les questions dans leur
globalité
sur l'hébergement et le cloud
vous voyez encore un terme souvent
en fait ça dépend comment vous avez ce
que vous définissez normaux souvent pour
moi souvent ça veut dire qu'on maîtrise
ça veut dire qu'on comprend vous dire
qu'il ya personne qui va piocher dedans
ou dehors de nos propres services donc
on maîtrise donc on comprend donc moi je
crois que c'est important qu'ils aient
du cloud combattre y ce qu'on comprend
est ce que ça veut dire que on doit en
créer un exil ni l'eau avec des gens qui
n'ont peut-être jamais fait avant ou que
l'état doit lui-même pour sûr ça alors
que c'est pas son métier ça je n'y crois
pas est ce que on a parmi les meilleurs
opérateurs en europe ou dans le monde
sur notre territoire la réponse est oui
et le lunch par exemple il y en a deux
trois autres aussi d'excellents niveaux
européen et mondial
cela participe à notre souveraineté de
l'hébergement participent à notre
souveraineté du cloud et donc
l'intelligence c'est travailler avec eux
on l'a fait sur tous les autres sujets
on l'a fait sur le transport on l'a fait
sur les équipements les a faits sur les
équipements stratégiques préfet sur
l'armement il se trouve qu'on a des très
bons acteurs industriels l'intelligence
d'un pays c'est travailler avec ces
industriels je vais vous envoyer des
questions qui viennent de notre
communauté en direct
de quel budget médias et sur le
quinquina dispose-t-il pro mener à bien
toutes ces mesures alors il ya plusieurs
sujets sur lesquels je travaille il ya
transformation de l'état il ya trente
fois sur l'économie il y avait plusieurs
numérique il ya cybersécurité sur tous
ces sujets et c'est ça quand on est chef
d'état rattaché au premier ministre
j'utilise le budget des autres ce qui
est donc une position toujours
particulière anormal annonce très normal
moi je disais même que mon espoir c'est
d'être le dernier secrétaire d'état au
numérique et qu'il y en ait plus après
moi aujourd'hui dans le gouvernement il
ya des ministres qui sont très en avance
sur la maîtrise du studio numérique et
sur lequel je viens juste en tant que
les kilts et on va prendre exemple sur
la santé aujourd'hui la ministre de la
santé est le pilote ce sujet consacré un
sujet essentiel elle l'inclût elle va
avoir son propre label a décidé d'avoir
sa propre capacité d'innovation interne
sur ces sujets de santé comme on a créé
en interministériel avec et à la bhl
comme on l'a créée avec toute l'équipe
de la boutique elle devrait avoir cette
capacité là aussi en interne la ministre
de la justice qui en a fait le troisième
pilier de la transformation de la
justice en france et ben moi je vais
créer les moyens de l'état et les
briques essentielles pour qu'elle puisse
avancer sur leurs projets mais elles ont
un très fort a lancé le milieu éducation
nationale pour lui c'est un sujet
aujourd'hui de transformation il va
développer dans les prochains mois c'est
autant de sujets sur lesquels moi
j'apporte expertise je porte des règles
qui vont permet que ce soit plus simple
pour eux de développer des nouveaux
outils s'appuie simple pour eux
d'apporter une nouvelle réflexion de
nouvelles méthodes sur la façon de faire
des services publics à l'heure du
numérique en gros le numérique c'est un
outil le numérique c'est un sujet
d'études d'observation et c'est un
phénomène de transformation de la
société bon bah chacun se pose cette
question là donc sur le budget il ya le
budget french tech & start up qui est
qui est un budget qui existe depuis
toujours sur lequel on a décidé
d'augmenter le volet diversité sur
transformation du muguet tpe pme ça
s'inscrit dans le budget global est de
la loi que vous apportez moi bruno le
maire début 2018 sur le sujet
transformation de l'état là c'est dans
le cas de ce fameux fonds de 700
millions d'euros pour la transformation
de l'état qui doit permettre de créer
ces nouveaux objets numériques de l'état
et sa fibre à 700 millions en fait c'est
700 millions en plus
du budget de l'état c'est que le budget
numérique de l'état c'est près de 10
milliards d'euros par an donc 10
milliards d'euros par an ce n'est pas si
petit bras que ça par contre est-ce que
c'est bien utilisé est-ce que c'est
parfaitement optimisé je vous le réponse
est non aujourd'hui on a un écosystème
applicatif de l'état avec plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'applications
maintenu avec beaucoup qui parfois font
la même chose on n'a pas encore une
intelligence collective de l'utilisation
des moyens numériques et dans la
relation entre l'état les collectivités
locales n'ont plus aujourd'hui à des
services que mais y compris des très
petites collectivités sont amenés à tout
redévelopper chacune donc regarder non
de département regardez le nombre de
régions et regardez le nombre de
communes regardez ce que l'état pourrait
quand même leur proposer sur sa faim des
sujets alors deux questions encore de
l'inconnu de la communauté en parlant
d'ailleurs de budget est ce que l'état
fait tilt sous-traiter certaines de ces
tâches de surveillance numériques à des
sociétés privées vous parlez de quel
sujet renseignements géré enseignement
et à faire baisser les coûts est ce que
vous faites sous traiter certaines
tâches ce sujet je peux pas vous
répondre et surtout c'est pas moi qui
sont en charge de ces sujets là avec ce
sont des sujets qui dépendent du
ministère d'intérêt du ministère des
armées donc c'est pas c'est pas moi qui
pilote
sur les logiciels espions de
surveillance vous êtes un peu au courant
ou pas du tout c'est pas moi et encore
une fois sur ses logiciels là qui
assurent notre sécurité c'est pas moi
qui vous avez entendu parler du sujet
pas du tout j'ai entendu parler du sujet
je suis vendeuse gouvernement j'étais
président du conseil national du
numérique donc oui j'ai entend parler de
ces sujets mais je ne suis pas informé
haut niveau le plus élevé sur ces sujets
on va reprendre bientôt le fil de notre
interview une dernière question de la
communauté que pense-t-il des contrats
passés avec microsoft et apple au niveau
public
je l'avais annoncé quand j'étais
président du sénat où je disais que la
france aujourd'hui était pas
suffisamment bien organisée dans le
cadre de ses grands choix technologiques
et dans le cadre de la commande publique
numérique aujourd'hui on a lancé des
groupes de travail c'est là que la
aujourd'hui moi personnellement je
réunis très régulièrement tous les
déciles l'étape et on discute ensemble
dans le cas de huit groupes de travail
de différentes stratégies nouvelles
qu'on doit repenser ensemble dont une
qui s'appelle le poste de l'agent
aujourd'hui chaque administration chaque
collectivité chaque opérateur le dsi
doit se poser tout seul la question du
poste de l'agent quel logiciel va mettre
dedans quelle licence il va faire
qu'elle appelle des prix va lancer et
comment il va le porter alors qu'au
final il s'agit de nos agents publics
partout sur le territoire et que
collectivement si on décide d'utiliser
telle ou telle technologie on serait
plus intelligent de 2,2 de penser ça
collectivement que pour ses seins
individuellement donc moi je veux qu'on
remette à plat la faction qu'on a de
commandes et du numérique et d'acheter
du logiciel et d'acheter du hardware
vous avez quoi comme téléphone portable
j'en ai plusieurs
j'en ai un quand je vais à l'étranger
qui a un téléphone à 15 euros avec une
très bonne batterie qui fait zéro data
qui me permet d'être complètement serein
quand je voyage j'en ai un qui est qui
et j'ai un samsung à apple voilà comme
ça je vous dit tout vous savez installer
des applications dessus sur le samsung
mission à peu et vous savez qu'il faut
pas que vous donnent trop d'informations
non plus sur ce que j'utilise donc
disons que l'un est sécurisé et donc ne
me permet pas d'installer des
applications autres que celles
nécessaires aux appels sécurisé et
l'autre l'autre permet d'installer
d'autres applications qui sont
potentiellement pas sécurisé ou alors
qu'ils sont au moins issus de sources
considérées comme plus fiables je disais
un antivirus personnellement ça dépend
sur quel appareil chez vous en tout cas
je demande à tout le monde de le faire
donc j'essaye d'appliquer ces règles et
à moi-même lequel je peux pas vous
répondre
l'annoncé à tout le monde comment ça
c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien on
était avec des hackers russes de chez
kaspersky il n'y a pas très longtemps
c'est moi attrapé quelque chose
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'équation
de pardon équation racontez-moi
petit groupe de la nsa qui s'amusait à
regarder un peu partout
je connais pas le cas de l'équation et
je connais pas ce monsieur voulait poser
porter un camp près je veux dire que sur
les cadeaux dans les premiers rangs sont
des étrangers je reçois souvent des
cadeaux électroniques et je les jette
tout jeune et démontre juste pour être
sûr mais mais mais en fait il faut
jamais surpris d'y monter il faut les
filles et annecy pour qu'il reste viable
de vous ouais offert un peu de rétro
ingénierie sur ce qui se balance c'est
plus intéressant mais est ce que vous
vous êtes déjà tombés sur un objet rugby
en avant ses cinq ans quand on vous
donne des petits cadeaux bonus dans les
stations essence made in china ça peut
être très intéressant sur les clopes
électronique qui se recharge sur les sur
les bécanes c'est très intéressant vous
avez une clope électronique c'est bien
vos collaborateurs ont des clopes
électronique
et électronique c'est triste
les mesures de sécurité numérique au
sein du gouvernement on a beaucoup de
questions tout aussi beaucoup de
questions qui viennent un peu partout
les mesures de sécurité vous sortez d'un
mois de cybersécurité c'est ça a été
productif ce que l'anssi fait
correctement son boulot pour former nos
concitoyens à la sécurité informatique
est ce que vous trouvez que l'e-book de
l'ansea sont pédagogiques c'est pas une
question d'avoir le gouvernement et
l'état oui aujourd'hui on a une culture
de la sécurité numérique au sein de
l'état qui fait qu' on a tous conscience
des niveaux de sécurité des niveaux de
sensibilité des données qu'on échange et
qu'on manipule et que tout le monde a
été sensibilisé à bien utiliser le bon
canal en fonction des niveaux de
sensibilité qui ne veut merci comme à
bercy merci vous la fais le test sur le
sol au phishing mais là cela c'est
encore un autre sujet c'est que les
fonctionnaires de bercy ont été formés à
pas dans leur messagerie traditionnelle
envoyés du secret défense par exemple ou
a pas envoyé du confidentiel défense non
plus donc c'est vous qui défendez
clinton c'est ça non par contre hillary
clinton dixel qui nous a formés choix si
vous avez vu son livre dans ce livre
elle consacre une demi page en
expliquant que la raison pour laquelle
la campagne de d'emmanuel maquereau a
réussi à s'en sortir face aux hackers
c'est que grâce aux attaques qu'elle a
subies grâce à tout ce qu'elle a subies
au quotidien eh bien nous avons pu
apprendre ces attaques pour mieux vous
protéger vous aimez le sujet que je
voulais aborder que dans son interview m
ou salés macronix bas et macronix c'est
l'exemple que vous venez d'apprendre à
l'instant sur versé du phishing c'est le
phishing quand vous êtes là c'est quand
votre organisation est la cible d'une
campagne permanente de phishing quand
vous êtes fichés une à deux fois par
jour vous avez beau former tout le monde
vous avez beau envoyer des messages
réguliers vous avez beau essayer de
sensibiliser les personnes en fait quand
il ya en face de vous des attaquants de
très bon niveau
subtil intelligent
bien bien bien formés et que vous de
l'autre côté vous êtes une organisation
artisanale jean-paul qu'une campagne
électorale en france ces quelques
dizaines de personnes là où aux
etats-unis ces quelques centaines voire
quelques milliers nous l'équipe sécurité
dans la campagne c'est une personne et
demi l'équipe numérique ces dix
personnes donc oui on n'a pas mis en
place des dispositifs qui aurait été d
positif de détection il préalable du
phishing on a joué à la formation n'a
accompagné personnes et en a
quelques-uns qui sont fait piéger je
vous disais les fichiers il était quand
même et qu il était pixels perfect il
était absolument sûr que derrière ça il
ya quelqu'un qui a passé quelques heures
à chaque fois pour les envois le dernier
qui a été envoyé comme un bras d'honneur
qui était fait c'est un mail de moi à
toutes les équipes qui leur disait de
faire attention au phishing en leur
donnant un vrai un fichier word
accompagné c'était le c'est le plus beau
que c'était comme un good bye good bye
my phone c'était pour nous dire avoir
les on a fini maintenant bonne fin de
campagne au revoir à tous j'ai cru j'ai
cru lire dans un canard américain que
vous avez y est un toxique il les
attaquants comment vous avez procédé est
encore une fois vous comprenez que sur
ce sujet donné des détails ces cas c'est
la méthode donc on apprenait qu'on est
obligé de vous poser des questions vrai
eh ben je vous répondrai à hauteur de ce
que je peux vous dire qu'il est de dire
quand on est en mode artisanal quand on
sait qu'on sera pas capable de tout
protégé à 100% quand on sait que à la
fin il pourra se passer des choses et
bien sûr quelques adresses sur quelques
personnes sur quelques endroits et
quelques canaux on se dit que c'est
important de ralentir l'attaquant
ralenti l'attaquant ça peut être pour
ralentir la pénétration ça peut être
aussi pour ralentir le traitement de ce
qui pourra faire ensuite des données qui
l'aura capturés
dernière question sur sur ce sujet l'un
alors je le dis à celui qui a posé la
question je crois que ça a été retirée
d'ailleurs que pense-t-il de la loi qui
vient d'être votée je la mets entre
parenthèses sur le fait de devoir
divulguer ses identifiants et mots de
passe d'internet en cas de soupçon de
terrorisme
alors là dessus il faut bien être clair
cgc données l'identifiant c'est pas de
donner le mot de passe passe que les
boude pas son plaisir plus facile ou une
fois qu'on est l'identifiant vous avez
raison mais on parle de quatre
terroristes on parle de ses sujets mois
avant j'étais président du seigneur et
avant j'ai toujours été un militant dans
la vie ces syndicalistes s'étaient dans
tous ces sujets là aujourd'hui je suis
du côté où je suis au gouvernement
gouvernement ça veut dire que toute la
journée toute la semaine entre lyon du
gouvernement se poser les questions que
chacun doit se poser on a misé de
l'intérieur qui se pose comme question
permanente de comment nous protéger et
de comment éviter qu'ils un attentat en
france et de comment le faire moi je
m'intéresse assure la transformation de
la société et je me pose aussi la
question de la défense des libertés
publiques la ministre de la justice et
se pose en permanence la question des
libertés individuelles et ben y'a un
moment le conseil des ministres du
mercredi là pour ça chacun donne ses
contraintes chaque indice qui est ce
qu'il a à faire donner son identifiant
dans le cadre d'une enquête terroristes
dans le canal de suez mais moi j'étais
pas contre mais se trouve qu'il ya des
députés qui ont dit non parce que c'est
pas nécessaire et c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont proposé de le retirer donc voilà
philosophie du si vous transformez la
société par le numérique l'emploi
l'intelligence artificielle ça va se
comporter comment ces fameux emplois
magique qui vont héberger
vous ont tablé sur combien c'est
votre avis jouable est-ce que l'on va
pas se retrouver avec une classe moyenne
entièrement paupérisée le grand sujet
c'est celui de la transformation et de
la résilience et de la réadaptation des
personnes dans leur propre vie celui qui
vous dit le chiffre et vous ment ou
alors il est il se trompe c'est à celui
qui peut vous avez de laurent alexandre
c'est ça alors vous savez que leurs
excréments on s'entend très bien qu'il
va dédicacer des envieuses élections lui
vaut de bouquets on lui passe un message
parce que je sais qu'il ya ben moi je
veille à l'orangé du ton bouquin et
merci beaucoup et je les rencontre à
plusieurs reprises je partage pas par
contre c'est la vision complètement
en fait ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'il ya une question de curseur et de
timing et de rythme et le rôle du
politique c'est de gérer le gérer les
temps et d'être sûrs que les populations
sont capables de gérer les temps avec
les transformations qu'on est en train
de subir je pense que laurent alexandre
représente une figure m qui pousse le
curseur maximale avec la temporalité la
plus basse c'est à dire qu'il dit que
les transformations les plus majeurs
vont arriver très vite c'est plus un
registre en tout cas je dis que c'est
l'option maximale de l'autre côté il ya
une autre option qui dira rien arriver
vous inquiétez pas tout ça c'est du
pipeau ça va rien changer à notre
économie
ça c'est à peu près les deux les deux
positions extrêmes curseur la réalité
elle est entrée de la réalité elle et
c'est quand la fin de la voiture
carbonisée dans combien de temps ça va
arriver c'est quand la fin de tous les
emplois
d'assistant tous les emplois un papier
c'est dans deux ans et dans dix ans ça
va arriver là les emplois de chauffeurs
routiers du fret ça va disparaître c'est
dans cinq ans et dans dix ans la grande
question c'est d'être capable que ça
arrive dans deux ans ou dans dix ans de
forme et d'accompagner les personnes
d'où les 15 milliards d'euros du plan
compétences d'où cette transformation de
la philosophie qu'on a sur l'allocation
chômage aujourd'hui on l'entendait dans
les discussions on va ouvrir cette
allocation chômage à plus de gens on
veut que les gens puissent quitter un
job pour devenir entrepreneur si foire
l'antre leur entreprise eh ben ils vont
être indemnisés pour pouvoir retourner
dans l'emploi mais l'objectif c'est que
tout le monde puisse circuler dans les
différentes parce qu'il ya plus personne
qui va rester dans le cinq ans dans une
boîte donc il faut que les gens puissent
avoir un ou deux jobs s'ils ont envie il
faut qu'ils puissent faire un mi-temps
d'un côté et de l'entrepreneuriat de
l'autre faire un mi-temps d'un côté
faire un autre projet de vis de l'autre
photo et s'ils peuvent pas avoir un
doute shop mais s'ils peuvent pas avoir
un ou deux jobs alors ayez cette
allocation chômage et c'est cet
accompagnement la formation
professionnelle notre objectif quand on
se dit qu'on remet à plat toutes les
allocations chômage et la formation
professionnelle c'est à dire il n'y a
pas une seule personne en france sans
projet professionnel et sans projet de
compétences et c'est pour ça qu'on met
de l'argent si ça coûte cher c'est de
l'état est un combien cette année je
pourrai pas vous dis je pourrais pas
vous répondre immédiatement sur brood un
fidèle de l'état parce qu'il est en
pourcentage depuis bout alors il est en
noir ou en milliards et donc je crois
que entre 1600 et 2000 milliards donc je
ne serai pas vous dire le chiffre exact
autour des 2000
mais donc ce sujet de l' équilibre
social sur allocation chômage et de la
formation professionnelle ces salles
outils qu'on a décidé de mobiliser pour
permettre à chacun de vivre avec ces
temporalités là
vous parlez de l'échelle de temps de
curseur de temps parce que un moratoire
sur l'intelligence artificielle est
envisageable je veux bien le micro une
seconde est ce que vous pensez pas que
ces grands plans d'intelligence
artificielle mondiaux ça fait un peu
penser au nucléaire c'est à dire que
sortant de la guerre il nous fallait la
bombe il nous fallait de l'énergie
rapide et forte est-ce qu'on n'est pas
en train de courir après une chimère de
consommation exponentielle dans une
compétition où la guerre économique à
couteaux tirés règne ce que la france a
un rôle à jouer à dire écoutez les gars
peut-être ce qu'il met où est ce qu'on
va où est-ce qu'on veut aller
quand on voit les chinois qui veulent au
gré des leur nouvelle génération avec
des puces dans le cerveau augmenter leur
quotient intellectuel par sélection
papara sélection avec lorne à la méthode
chinoise
qu'est ce que vous en pensez c'est la
question des valeurs c'est à dire que
moratoire sur les technologies j'aime
jamais qu'on parle de ça par contre un
moratoire sur les usages saas et c'est
peut-être une question à avoir il faut
surtout jamais ralentir la capacité à
chercher la capacité à innover il faut
qu'on puisse se comprendre tout ce qui
se passe à ton intelligence artificielle
par contre dire que on ne souhaite pas
le robot autonome tueur au moins pour
les cinq prochaines années tant qu'on
n'aura pas discuté d'une intelligence
humaine pour comprendre ce qu'on
souhaite faire et c'est ça c'est c'est
totalement et spécifiquement ce que nous
souhaitons annoncé début 2010 8,6 reçu
le rapport dit là ni l'état va s'engager
sur certains sujets à regarder sujet
d'investissements des sujets d'éducation
des sujets de recherche mais aura aussi
les sujets éthiques on va dire ben on
pense que sur ce sujet ce sujet ce sujet
faut qu on lance un débat national qui
prendra peut-être 24 mois qui prendra
peut-être 18 mois sur lequel il faut
qu'on soit sûr que collectivement ce
soit bien la direction qu'on veut que la
france prenne et vous parler de l'humain
augmenté je pense que là aussi on a une
petite question de curseur donc ça c'est
pas peut-être pas la question qu'on doit
poser tout de suite début 2018 elle va
se poser pas vraiment après donc il faut
qu'on pose la question et voudra poser
la question aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
recherche en france sur de l'humain
augmenté en capacité de calcul par
exemple en capacité de stockage
qu'est-ce qu'on fait le projet la
première fois qu'un chercheur va nous
proposer sa caisse confère première fois
il ya une équipe qui fait bon ben voilà
on vous demande une autorisation
d'implantation d'un métier à mémoire
mais c'est pour les personnes
handicapées qui aurait qui ont subi un
choc et qui permettrait les aider ben on
voyait très bien comment ça va se passer
donc la question s'est il faut qu'on se
soit doté des outils intellectuels et
les outils intellectuels il faut juste
que les politiques les citoyens et les
chercheurs et ben se soit donné la
mission de réfléchir à ce sujet question
d'internet plus de robots moins de
travail est ce qu'il n'ya pas un risque
énorme de concentration des richesses en
tout cas c'est ce qu'on se disait sur le
rythme et la gestion du temps il ya bien
une question à se poser à moyen terme à
long terme sur le schéma de répartition
de la valeur henin qui on proposait le
revenu universel pendant la campagne on
l'a dit c'est pas le moment on n'a pas
dit ces abrutis comme comme réflexion
sinon il n'y aurait pas des gens très
talentueux qui en parlerait partout dans
le monde m'ont dit c'est pas maintenant
maintenant l'urgence c'est la capacité à
rebondir c'est la capacité à se reformer
c'est la capacité à s'adapter dans dix
ans si jamais on se dit c'est moi je
réfléchis souvent par scénario c'est à
dire que je ne crois pas tous ceux qui
me lisent ce sera comme ça sont des
menteurs si on dit la voiture autonome
électrique a permis de faire 100 % des
déplacements qu'il opère est ce que
c'est une grippe public est ce que c'est
une plateforme publique qui fait là la
répartition puis chacun a ses véhicules
est-ce que pourquoi ce serait pas le
public qui ferait tout il ya un scénario
où le public il aurait la propriété de
tous les véhicules appropriés toute la
grille depuis un scénario extrême de
l'autre côté avec plein de réseaux qui
se superposent des uns les autres pas de
standards communs avec des réseaux
concurrents qui règne je pense qu'entre
les deux il y aura la vérité aura un
rôle du public y aura un rôle plus si on
va dans un rôle extrême de l'autre côté
il peut aussi voir l'émergence d'un
monopole d'un acteur privé qui
concentrerait 100% de la valeur créée
par le transport en france et en europe
bon bah celui là s'ils opéraient tout de
façon complètement automatique où il a
juste fallu mettre beaucoup de capital
pour ensuite avoir le maximum de
véhicules à travers l'europe bon bah ça
posera des questions ça poserait la
question de comment taxe la valeur pour
la répartir pour le bien commun de tous
mais l'objectif c'est de garder notre
équilibre européens français on a un
équilibre en france qui fait qu'on est
français c'est on croit la socialisation
des risques on croit au fait qu' il faut
socialiser le risque de santé on croit
qu'il faut socialiser le risque de perte
d'emploi et ça ça fait partie de notre
philosophie on n'est pas français si on
croit pas c'est ce qui nous différencie
de beaucoup de pays dans le monde c'est
ce qui fait aussi qu'on a des pays où on
a des affinités intellectuelles
on pense qu'être malade c'est quelque
chose qu'on va prendre encore fait un
cancer c'est un truc ça doit me sais pas
vous le ps et ensemble on va le prendre
c'est pas le cas d'autres continents
l'un d'eux interdit l'utilisation du
moins est en train d'interdire
l'utilisation des voitures autonomes
et protégé de l'emploi alors aujourd'hui
c'est dans une phase de transition c'est
à dire que c'est cette fameuse gestion
du temps et ça pose beaucoup de
questions donc je vais pas vous dire si
je trouve ça bien ou pas bien que notre
pays ait décidé de faire ça mais je dis
je comprends que des élus politiques des
citoyens se posent la question si on
leur a pas proposé des solutions de
résilience de voir tous ces emplois
disparaître du jour au lendemain après
en france par exemple sur le véhicule
autonome des questions joly c'est plutôt
le niveau de qualité de sécurité de ses
véhicules avant de les mettre dans
l'espace public aujourd'hui on se pose
pas encore la question de responsables
donc exactement qui sera un des grands
sujets de discussion
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont internet encore
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour contrer les
stratégies d'optimisation fiscale des
grandes entreprises numériques américain
n ya pas que les américains donc qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour les grandes
entreprises transnationales nouvelle
génération qui créent de la valeur sur
un continent mais en fait la vente sur
un autre on concentration de
l'intelligence et de la valeur ajoutée
un endroit
en gros il faut revenir à des concept
basique quand il ya des entreprises
massivement qui payent pour une
entreprise dans un endroit on a du mal à
comprendre que l'entreprise qui encaisse
tout cet argent ne participe pas à la
solidarité dans le pays où tout a été
payé donc aujourd'hui on a plusieurs
chantiers de travail avec plusieurs
temporalités différentes et l ocde où on
arrivera je pense d'ici cinq ans
peut-être un peu moins j'espère - un
accord international y compris que les
états unis y compris avec eux tous les
grands acteurs y compris que les chinois
sur une nouvelle façon de penser la
fiscalité dans cet espace transnational
ça prendra beaucoup de temps
ensuite
il se posera la question
de
il se pose la question au niveau
européen
européenne au cd on sera avec les
américains il faudra qu'on aille
convaincre les chinois mais chinois sur
le c2 n'y arriveront pas au niveau
européen il faut qu'on fasse attention
parce qu'on va mettre de trois ans
mettent d'accord sur laxiste pour qu'on
ait une assiette commune sauf que si on
n'a pas discuté d'abord avec les
américains et chinois eh ben on n'aura
pas la capacité à les taxer dans
l'espace européen donc il faut qu'on
arrive sur axis qui est une assiette
commune qui permet de faire que au moins
entre nous on arrête de se faire
concurrence c'est aujourd'hui un des
gros problème c'est qu'au sein de
l'union dont je vous ai parlé cette
fraternité dans laquelle on partage tout
sur la fiscalité banon partagez pas et
en plus on se faisait parfois des
découpes à les uns aux autres et puis à
la troisième temporalité que bruno le
maire est allé porter au niveau européen
qu emmanuel macron kindia bomba avant
qu'on ait réussi sur axis avant qu'on
ait réussi sur les autres avant qu'on
ait trouvé un accord avec des chinois
avant qu'on ait trouvé un accord avec
les américains tout de suite on va
mettre en place un dispositif temporaire
qui durera le temps qu'on arrive à l'un
de ces accords mais qui va permettre de
taxer le chiffre d'affaires payer dans
ces entreprises aujourd'hui en france on
paye plusieurs milliers à nos
entreprises en pub en ligne elle paye
plusieurs milliards d'euros en france à
des entreprises basées à l'étranger sur
lequel un trade infime impôts est payé
en solution c'est autant de richesses
qui part et on participe à la mère
commune donc c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on se mobilise
est ce que vous êtes pour ou contre les
portes dérobées
dans les entreprises
alors
ce contre quoi je suis de façon complète
vous parlez des pans dérobé dans les
outils dans l'est c'est
l'industrialisation de la porte dérobée
et le fait qu' il ya des portes dérobées
by default ça je suis contre et axa
c'est ce qu'on doit empêcher c'est ce
qu'il faut absolument éviter
après est-ce que les portes dérobées
sont un outil qui peut être utilisée
parfois quand elles sont dans un cadre
contrôlé oui oui et c'est important que
ça puisse exister
parce que c'est ce qui va permettre
aussi vous savez bien que retrouve les
portes dérobées où des pirates
informatiques des gens des black cats
viennent trouver cette porte la garde
pour nous faire un peu plaisir le but
intelligents notamment dans une
procédure judiciaire quand comme s'ils
s'étaient rendues possibles c'est que
sous contrôle d'un juge de façon
temporaire dans un cadre ciblées on en a
eu la gagne et qu'on ait la capacité de
le faire aujourd'hui
le fait de le faire de façon
systématique c'est ça le plus grand
danger c'est de se dire que il
dispositif qui soit dans le grand public
ait dans toutes les entreprises qui ont
des portes dérobées et la grande
question c'est à qui on dit qu'elle
existe cette porte dérobée ou alors ceux
à qui on ne le dit pas qui la découvrent
comment ils utilisent aujourd'hui il ya
des soupçons de
d'éditeurs qui aurait mis à très grande
échelle des portes dérobées dans des
softwares dans des hard way retour du
téléphone dans des airs de la dent des
softwares partout
pour poupe c'est bon ça c'est bon ça
c'est bon
on va passer à un autre sujet twitter la
liberté d'expression
quand twitter
black bull les médias russes qu'est ce
que vous en pensez qu'est ce que vous
appelez black boulet ne pu
recevoir du moins à ne plus accepter les
revenus publicitaires du moins de
sponsorisation de leurs publications
pour faire pulser ou peser leurs
publications quand tu quand vous donnez
de l'argent à twitter pour mettre en
avant leurs publications twitter a dit
s'est terminée à cause de l'ingérence
supposée de
la russie aux états unis ça c'est un des
sujets là je ne m'exprime ni sur le
cadre spécifique de twitter ni sur cas
spécifiques que vous décidez aborder des
russes mais en général et notamment avec
le débat qui commence aux états unis
depuis quelques heures
qu'est ce qu'on fait de cette nouvelle
capacité qui fait que des organisations
peuvent mettre du fric à destination de
plateforme où grâce à la capacité à
créer des contenus et à payer de la pub
on arrive à toucher beaucoup de
personnes comment on fait pour tracer
l'origine de cet argent comment on fait
pour trash et le tracé trachée pour
tracer la volonté qui est derrière cet
investissement comment on fait pour
comprendre quel est le cycle d'intérêts
entre les personnes aujourd'hui c'était
ma conviction pendant la campagne et
j'en suis aujourd'hui convaincu
qu'on est dans un nouveau schéma de
risque géostratégique notamment liée au
cyber c'est à dire qu'on a des
organisations indépendantes qui parfois
sont rattachés un état parfois pas
parfois financés par un état parfois pas
parfois financés par des mafias parfois
autofinancé par leurs propres activités
criminelles ou par des entreprises ou
par des entreprises dans le cadre
d'activités légal ou illégal qui vont
attaquer d'autres organisations ou
attaquer d'autres états et qui vont
créer des alliances base et parfois sur
les idées on a des groupuscules
philosophique notamment dans les
extrêmes on a une internationale de
l'extrême droite fasciste on a une
internationale des ultraconservateurs la
une international du libéralisme on a eu
notre nation je sais pas en tout cas pas
dans le pas dans le cyber vous avez
l'impression qu'ils s'organisent pour
hacker ça je pourrais pas vous dire que
j'étais peut-être l'impression aussi qui
s'organise aussi pour faire pulser leurs
idées à travers certains médias trouvent
connaissez la structure fine la fing la
structure fils astroturf helbaoui je
vois bien ce cas-là ce trotteur fing et
et je vois très bien que j'ai pu parfois
le vivre très fort sur ces sujets là la
question c'est au nom de quoi ce fait
les coalitions au nom de quoi se font
l'écho action moi je crois pas au fait
que ya derrière personnes qui
réfléchissent mais je crois pas non plus
au fait qu' un gode design c'est qu'il
n'ya pas un mec dans une salle qui fait
toi tu as mené dufry toi tu vas me
donner des idées nous on va faire ce
truc là rendez vous jeudi prochain on
fait notre truc je crois plus à moi j'ai
un intérêt très fort à ce que maintenant
en high s'opposer à lui il se trouve que
pour m'opposer à lui je me propose qu'on
fasse ça ça ça et ça toi regarde si tu
as envie de venir bien toi cette envie
de venir vient mais que tout se fasse de
façon un peu informé l'eau
organiser un mélange de argent
compétences et volonté politique et ça
c'est très nouveau parce que ça peut
dépasser la capacité des états à nous
protéger ça peut dépasser la capacité d
organiser à se protéger
pour
excuser moi les civic tech le vote
électronique
c'est save s'est passé fait ce qu'on
peut pas subir un petit hack de nous
deux nous civique tai chi ou de nos
machines à voter
à part exactement du vote électronique
et des services publics numériques et de
la sécurité aujourd'hui le premier
chantier qu'on vient de lancer là et qui
est essentiel c'est avec le président on
a annoncé la numérisation de 100% des
démarches public pour ça la condition
essentielle c'est l'usagé que j'en sache
utiliser et la deuxième condition c'est
la sécurité est la clef de cette
sécurité
et cette intelligence c'est ce qu'on a
voulu appeler la plateforme numérique de
l'état plateforme numérique de l'état
c'est une architecture qui doit
permettre un l'identification et
l'authentification à plusieurs niveaux
faibles jusqu'à forte de une
interconnexion
utile dans le cas des usages des
différentes données qui doivent
permettre un initiateur ne pas
réutiliser ne pas avoir déclaré
différentes données et une troisième
brique dans cette plateforme numérique
de l'état qui est une brique contrôle et
qu'une brique dans l' architecture qui
by design doit protéger les données
personnelles des personnes qui font
qu'on peut pas faire d'interconnexion de
données sans passer par cette brique là
et l'objectif d'avoir ces trois briques
c'est de pouvoir créer des nouveaux
services publics des nouveaux micros
service de nouveaux grands services qui
sont basés sur cette authentification
sécurisée fortes garanties par l'état
cette interconnexion et cette protection
à cette couche de protection des données
si on veut faire le vote électronique il
faut qu'on soit très fort sur les 3 il
faut qu'on soit face surtout sur le
notification et sur la brique de
contrôle est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui le gouvernement et l'état a
pas souhaité autoriser le vote
électronique lors des dernières
élections c'était pas une culture et
donc je peux d'autant plus le levante
c'est qu'on considérait que les
conditions de sécurité n'étaient pas
réunies on considère que après avoir
testé les dispositifs on se disait que
c'était peut-être pas le bon moment pour
le faire
question sur les lanceurs d alerte il ya
une vraie loi quid de la loi sapin le
cas julian assange qui a un gamin en
france qui est encore dans son ambassade
de l'autre côté de la manche qu'est ce
que vous en pensez assange nous donne là
stéphanie gibout il ya ce que je pense
en général de l'année c'était de ça et
puis il ya sur ces cas particuliers où
comme je voulais tard je pourrais pas me
prononcer spécifiquement et vous dire
que ça c'est un sujet qui est
spécifiquement entre les mains la misa
justice de l'intérieur et qui sont des
sujets sur lesquels il faut faire
attention à pas non plus créer de trou
est-ce que je crois une cité des plaies
de la capacité d'avoir des lanceurs
d'alerté qui qui serait ensuite protégé
parce qu'ils dénoncent des éléments qui
vont permettre plus de démocratie qui
vont permettre plus à libération de la
parole plus de libération oui puisqu'il
faut faire gaffe aussi à créer un
contexte qui fait que ces personnels se
mettent à elle même dans une illégalité
parce que dans ce qu'elles vont faire
elles vont pouvoir
enfreindre plusieurs lois et règlements
aussi donc en fait il faut qu'on crée
une capacité des circuits de protection
pour cette libération de la parole sur
le cas assange c'est un peu particulier
vous savez très bien ce qui se passe
c'est pas sur son c'est pas sur l'aspect
de lanceurs dallaire qui a aujourd'hui
une complexité juridictionnelle c'est
sur d'autres éléments auxquels je me
prendre si je vous dis lyon direct avec
nous est ce que vous lui parlez moi je
peux le saluer moi je l'écouté très
souvent des conférences j'ai écouté à
des cyber conférence je l'écoutais à
south by southwest ya trois ans où il
était en cyber représentation
distance moi je trouve très intéressant
et tous les éléments de salut tu trouve
très intéressant tous les éléments de
philosophie qu'il a pu porter
on va on va revenir sur l'intelligence
artificielle la formation des enfants le
ministère de l'éducation nationale est
ce qu'il est vraiment conscient des
mutations à venir ouais il est conscient
et aujourd'hui il est en pleine
réflexion aussi alors après vous savez
on quand on arrive on réinvente pas tout
c'est à dire que il se passe des choses
et luc et sociale depuis longtemps on
forme les enfants au sujet du numérique
ont formé enfants plusieurs choses on
les forme à l'analyse critique de
l'information qui leur est posée ce que
un enfant aujourd'hui à plusieurs
moments de sa scolarité il va être amené
à s'interroger sur d'où vient cette
information qu'il a produit et est ce
que j'en suis le destinataire est ce que
je peux avoir une attitude critique
vis-à-vis de cette information ça c'est
un élément important
après vous avez dit heures numérique
c'est à la fois un outil donc c'est pour
ça qu'ils là dessus on est un peu en
retard donc faut qu'on avance aussi et
pour moi l'outil c'est pas juste les
tablets et il ya plein de choses qu'on
peut faire aujourd'hui avec le numérique
on fait pas le numérique c'est aussi un
sujet d'étude donc là je vous ai parlé
du sujet analyse critique des médias
nice critique des médias numériques moi
je pense qu'il ya un bagage technique
technologique numérique de base que tout
le monde va là dessus je pense
d'ailleurs que les chaînes publiques au
fur et à mesure des années un peu
abandonné leur rôle de médiateur des
sciences médiateur du numérique
médiateur des industries on a perdu des
émissions fantastique il était une fois
la vie vous savez que je lire posté sur
mon twitter parce que il a ils les ont
recolorisées ils les ont remis en bonne
qualité et ils dansent à moi c'était
bien mais la série diffusée en ce moment
mais c'est pas diffusé à l'heure du
matin ou sortie de l'école mais c'est
diffusé et au moins ça a été restauré
donc ça c'est pas mal non mais moi je
trouve que c'est pas sorcier c'était une
émission fantastique qui a permis à
beaucoup de jeunes de sa culture et aux
sciences et de sa culture numérique je
pense que il ya un sujet sur le
numérique ces ondes il faut coder
fauconnet moi je m'en fiche qu'on
apprenne le codage aux enfants jeux
qu'on leur apprenne l'idée et le concept
même d'information cette idée que l'on
peut la stocker la transférer la
modifier quelle passe à travers des
réseaux qu'elle peut aller d'un endroit
à un autre que ces réseaux ils peuvent
prendre différentes formes physiques mon
physique matériel dans les ombres et que
entre
l'interface le stockage la transmission
et l'écran tout ça c'est un ensemble est
un continuum et en fait quand on fait 10
heures de code quand on fait 10 15
heures 20 heures de code c'est ça qu'on
apprend bah ça je pense que tous les
français devraient le faire parce que ça
ne daignait serait tout ça que regarder
un écran sens profondément ressentir
vibrer l'idée que c'est un objet ouvert
à plein de choses que c'est quoi c'est
renoncer à toute une partie de la
compréhension du monde je les dis à une
conférence ressemble j'étais à sciences
po vraiment dans toute la salle il y
avait qu un tiers des élèves c'est déjà
pas mal un tiers qui avait fait une
introduction au code j'ai réduit aux
deux tiers c'est comme si vous viviez
dans un monde où en fait il vous manque
et la moitié de la formation de savoir
comment ça fonctionne ça vous aide dans
la caverne vous voyez des onglets vous
croyez que c'est la réalité est en fait
derrière il se passe énormément de
choses et ça vous en donner le monopole
à ceux qui maîtrisent donc on doit
jamais donné monopole à ceux qui
maîtrisent part qu'on va pas tous
transformer nos jeunes ingénieurs
au collège par contre on va déniaisé
tout le monde sur le sujet du numérique
vous parliez de traitement de
l'information qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'il
fait que nous
les fait mieux c'est un phénomène sur
lequel aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de faux
pas de consensus sur comment les traiter
parce que les acceptait les journalistes
qui ont
oublié les commandes non de la charte de
munich par exemple le traitement sur les
armes de destruction massive c'était une
fête news qui a été popularisé un peu à
gauche à droite
certaines manoeuvres géopolitique la
population se retrouve au milieu de
manoeuvre géopolitique de certains états
et nous la france nos journalistes se
sont arrangées
avec la parole de l'état et ont servi
certaines facs news et donc le public a
perdu confiance dans le traitement de
l'information est devenue peut-être plus
réceptifs au fait que nous provenant
d'autres états taux de partis d'autres
points de vue ce qui est compliqué avec
la techno c'est qu'elle ressemble
gagneuse sinon elle poserait pas de
problème c'est l'accès affectueuse était
suffisamment abrutis c'était
suffisamment
vulgaire les gens se rendrait compte
assez facilement problème c'est que la
fait que news la fosse news le complot
ça ressemble à la vérité ça ressemble
aux vrais est pire que ça vous me donnez
des exemples ça ressemble au vrai qu'on
souhaite et donc on peut être amené à
elle été un tweet ou que les toits suède
ou que moi quand vous disiez un autre
état ou au moins si je me sens pas bien
dans mon état je me dis ah enfin une
source qui répond à mes valeurs et qui
avance
le sujet là dessus c'est qu'il ya des
sources de fake news qui sont
aujourd'hui des médias avec des vrais
journalistes à l'intérieur et donc
comment vous dites plaisir avec notre
argent comment payer avec notre argent
non parce qu'ils sont pas tous
subventionnés
tous touchent pas enfin prenons par
exemple trop spécifique parce que c'est
un sujet complexe et polémiques en tous
cas ce qui est certain c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on soit
capable les journalistes l'état les
citoyens tout le monde d'avoir une
approche sur ce qu'on considère comme
étant de l'information traitée par des
journalistes avec la rigueur des
journalistes et d'une rédaction ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il peut pas y avoir de
point de vue c'est ce qu'on a toujours
défendu en france l'idée qu'on devait
avoir du journalisme d'opinion du
journalisme de point de vue du
journalisme aux kings qui n'est pas
neutre journalisme c'est pas juste
informer c'est pas le rôle des journées
s'est informé pays isa na li et puis
d'ici depuis 2000 direction aussi ça
faut qu'on le célèbre et qu'on le décide
la question c'est on peut avoir des
opinions très biaisée à ce moment là il
faut que ça soit assumé je suis un média
biaisé et voilà mme ameline d'opinion
puis après il ya la frontière qui est le
mensonge il ya quand on dit quelque
chose qui est faux et qu'on construit
autour de ce fonds des éléments qui font
sans ressembler ce fois de la vérité est
là il faut qu'on soit capable de
l'identifier et d'y mettre fin ça peut
nous emmener en guerre c'est ça je sais
pas si ça peut non c'est pas la question
n'est pas de nous amener en guerre mais
c'est de dire des choses qu'on ne
tolérerait pas dans l'espace physique
c'est à dire que si
un groupe extrémiste ou un état étranger
venez placardées dans toutes les rues de
paris des affiches de propagande eh ben
on interdirait physiquement on c'est
auprès les personnes si on a vu tous les
médias français nous servir du hillary
clinton contre trump et ils sont plantés
98% parce que c'est rome qui est passé
interpréter ça comment alors là c'est du
billard à trois bandes là c'est pas de
la techno c'est celle de la structure
fine pratiquement non
c'est vous qui faites une analyse qui
n'est pas encore faite aux états unis de
savoir quel a été le rôle de la fée cnsa
ce trotteur fing et de l'investissement
de publicité sur les réseaux sociaux
dans la manipulation de l'opinion
publique américaine et ensuite de
l'opinion publique mondiale et des
journalistes
aujourd'hui on n'a pas d'élément complet
les enquêtes sont lancés les discussions
sont lancés on sait pas vraiment d'où ça
vient aujourd'hui une enquête sur la
russie mais c'est toujours plus complexe
que qu'est d'identifier une seule cible
c'est toujours toujours beaucoup plus
complexe et donc aujourd'hui est ce que
c'est ça le contexte qui a fait gagner
l'un plutôt que l'autre je sais pas
encore j'attends de voir des enquêtes
mais par contre je vous assure que la
france aujourd'hui essaient de se doter
des capacités d analyse de tous ces
phénomènes on arrive pratiquement la fin
de notre interview vous avez des sujets
que vous les abordez vous voulu faire
presser notre communauté alors moi j'ai
lancé des factures alors j'ai un sujet à
vous merci d'avoir incité le manifeste
des hackers lors de votre audition aux
affaires économiques ça nous a fait
plaisir et voilà merci et puis vous
savez vous avez quand même je les lui
dans un discours que j'ai fait à
communauté france digital il ya quelques
semaines et qui est un élément essentiel
mais ça je vais le garder pour après
parce que d'abord je vous demander un
service à toute la communauté qui est de
les 20 millions de lé 13 millions de
français dont le solaire les 20000 et
20% eux c'est un truc sur lequel on va
tous se mobiliser c'est ce qu'ils savent
pas utiliser serre qu'il ya ceux qui
n'ont pas accès au réseau et là on s'est
mobilisé avec les opérateurs pour que
tout le monde ait accès d'après il ya
ceux qui comme un ami à l'axé savent pas
utiliser dans tout ce qu'on fait au
quotidien dans tous les services
concrets dans tout ce qu'on développe
faut comprendre à ses 13 millions là il
faut qu'on soit tous capables
d'accompagner cette transformation vers
eux ensuite aux hackers qu'est ce que
j'en pense d'eux et qu'est ce qui dans
la partie du manifesto j'ai cité est
essentiel c'est cette idée de se
reconnaître entre soi entre les premiers
qui ont vu les choses mais ce qui est
important dans ce manifeste c'est les
valeurs ont étudié pourquoi on fait les
choses et quand je cite sage je redis
une chose est requis et bien c'est
important quand on s'est senti seul de
retrouver enfin quelqu'un qui nous
ressemblent de enfin se dire qu'on fait
communauté se dire que cette vision du
monde qu'on a qui nous a soutenus
souvent isolés pendant l'enfance fait
que en fait là on se retrouve avec
d'autres gens qui pensent à la vitesse
qu'ils regardent à peu près les mêmes
choses au même endroit qui ont ces mêmes
réflexes ça c'est juste une étape de la
vie de se sentir mieux avec ça après
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et dans le
discours j'avais cité un autre texte
après qu'est la nuit des enfants rois
qui est qu'est ce qui se passe quand
ceux qui se reconnaissent enfin n'ont
plus de valeur et deviennent les ennemis
deviennent les ennemis les plus
dangereux du peuple et quand on a des
valeurs alors on peut devenir ce qui
transforme
les civilisations qui transforme nos
états qui transforme en eau économie
donc un des grands sujets c'est de se
poser la question de me valeur se poser
la question de notre utilité au
quotidien pourquoi on fait ces choses
pourquoi et à quoi elle doit servir la
compétence et la capacité
aujourd'hui on a l'opportunité de faire
un numérique à la française en numérique
à l'européenne qui portent nos valeurs
partout dans le monde et on est regardé
par certains continents qui ont pas
envie de regarder ce continent lacan pas
envie de regarder celui-là nous qui nous
regardent nous comme une capacité à
influencer bas à nous d'être à la
hauteur de cette influence et ça c'est
une responsabilité qu'on a les hackers
se sont retrouvés maintenant il faut
qu'ils s'ouvrent et l'enjeu c'est donner
toute la société avec nous donc c'est ça
la philosophie
en général on me pose une question nous
inviter qui est la dernière mais ce sera
pas la dernière sera l'avant-dernière
peut-être laissé un conseil aux jeunes
générations un prisme de lecture à moyen
long terme
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
une bouteille à la mer concerts avortés
sur les réseaux
le conseil aux jeunes générations et il
est celui qui est toujours le plus
important c'est celui de l'utilité aux
autres et il faut toujours se poser la
question de la performance de l'humanité
et moi j'ai résume dans l'utilité fais
moi mon ma volonté paix relancées
comment je peux être utile aux gens
autour de moi quand je peux être utile
aux autres si on réfléchit en permanence
cette question de l'utilité alors ça
modifie notre façon de choisir et ça
peut porter nos meutre notre notre
système de valeurs donc soyez utile aux
autres soit utile à vous même et et
soyez toujours efficace pour défendre
vos valeurs seuils et des valeurs fortes
pensées et soyez certains que l'idée
d'aider un autre humain et de se
construire une pièce plus essentiel que
tout est que pour ça il ya des façons
efficaces de le faire il ya un conseil
pour protéger sa vie privée le conseil
pour protéger sa vie privée c'est celui
que j'essaye de porter aux nues au ps a
suivi ces deux de créer dans les
nouvelles mécaniques économique on est
en train de vivre en ce moment c'est
comment les grands acteurs du numérique
comment les grandes dynamiques du
numérique aujourd'hui elles font qu'on
n'est pas des prisonniers et que leur
système économique soient pas des
prisons qui s'échangent des prisonniers
où je passe 5 10 ans dans un système
apple puis je passe 5 10 ans un système
google ou alors je suis double
prisonniers entre deux trucs et ensuite
leur facture ça à tous les autres je
veux que pour qu'on se protège de tout
ça ce soit nous qui maîtrisions ce soit
nous qui tient j'aime bien votre service
de mail je vais vous mettre à
disposition tout le monde historique de
mails puis jour où j'ai promis de passer
par chez vous je reprends tout puis je
refais ça chez un autre il faut qu'on
arrive à cet praticité là et donc ça ça
veut dire plus de concurrence plus
d'opérateurs plus de capacité à changer
régulièrement moi j'utilise plusieurs
services et plusieurs services d'e-mails
plusieurs services de messagerie
personnelle j'ai plusieurs réseaux
sociaux j'essaye de ne pas avoir tous au
même endroit et j'essaye d'être certain
que j'ai bien la capacité à pouvoir
partir et aller là où je loupe une
source l'opensuse j'y crois très fort
l'open source pour l'état on dit la
solution souveraine c'est l'open source
à une condition c'est qu'on maîtrise
c'est pour ça que au sein de la
dynamique maintenant on a des personnes
qui à temps plein sont des contributeurs
si on veut un open source qui soit utile
à l'état qui soient utiles aux
entreprises - l'appel que j'ai fait à
tous et mettez nous dessert mettez des
salariés contributeurs serre que vous ne
vous pourrez dire que cette solution est
bonne pour vous que si vous participez à
la construire donc au sein de l'état on
l'a on a des acteurs de on a des
participants à cet open source moi je
suis pour qu'ils aient plus d'open
source mais jamais imposé l'open source
parce que si on a posé une panne cela
qu'on ne maîtrise pas alors recréer une
nouvelle faille de souveraineté dans le
dispositif
microsoft dont l'armée
microsoft dans l'armée microsoft
ailleurs vous savez microsoft c'est un
des outils préférés de beaucoup d agents
parce qu'ils ont été formés à
traditionnellement à ça parce qu ils le
maîtrisent très bien parce qu'ils
connaissent par coeur les interfaces
parce qu'ils connaissent par coeur la
facilité d'utilisation et dans ces cas
là on va pas dire aux jambes un nom du
jour en main va le changer par contre
est-ce qu'on doit se poser la question
tiens pour tel type d'agent ou tient
pour tel type de service on a réussi à
créer une interface qui est plus adapté
parce qu'on a créé des meilleurs outils
et on a des contributeurs qui font
qu'aujourd'hui libreoffice pour tel ou
tel secteur ce sera encore mieux que ce
libreoffice ont admis mme bricq sécurisé
qui fait que votre workflow il a encore
plus efficace que tient pour les profs
on a mis en place dans sa tel est l
élément en fait il faut qu'on pense en
qualité d'usagé en qualité de service ça
moi j'ai rien contre microsoft moi je
sais très bien qu'ils aient des licences
microsoft partout on a souhaité qu' en
est par contre je trouve que c'est très
bien qu'on maîtrise beaucoup mieux
libreoffice qu'on participe plus à faire
du libreoffice et que au fur et à mesure
on développe ses nouveaux usages un
homme tire ça vous parle pas la langue
tire ça me bats je pense que c'est très
important
aujourd'hui on est en europe des grands
acteurs qu'ils soient capables d'offrir
des services de traitement massif de
données obtenues légalement qui
permettent de créer de l'intelligence
artificielle sur ses usages y compris
sur les usages sécurisé y compris sur
les usages secret et qu'on soit jamais
dépendant d'un seul fournisseur dans le
monde qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
l'afrique
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour l'afrique
qu'est ce que l'afrique fait pour elle
et comment l'aide c'est ça la
philosophie aujourd'hui l'afd par
exemple agence française de
développement qui délivre notre
coopération à travers le monde elle a
mis le numérique comme un de ces
nouveaux piliers et elle a même mesuré
l'impact du numérique dans ses piles et
elle dit quand on finance en afrique en
partenariat avec les opérateurs privés
et les communautés des dispositifs
numériques à destination des citoyens on
a plus d'impact sur les citoyens au
final donc aujourd'hui c'est la première
fois c'est la première fois que l'afd
fait des investissements en disant tiens
nous avait on va penser la coopération
comme de l'innovation et ça ça a déjà
des débuts d'impact après je vais pas
vous dire aujourd'hui on finance surtout
des infrastructures d'accès à l'eau des
routes et l'éducation mais le numérique
devient un nouveau pilier qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour l'afrique afrique
on peut acheter ses services aujourd'hui
il ya une afrique à tech francophone qui
est en train de faire émerger des
services qu'aucun start up heure
française a fait émerger c'est à dire
des objets qu'ils utilisent moins de
réseau qui consomment moins de capacités
parce qu'un à moins sur place qui
aujourd'hui peuvent devenir des modèles
aujourd'hui on a un modèle un axe
francophones qui pourrait nous permettre
de développer des nouveaux usages et
puis après il ya toujours sur cet axe
francophone ce que nous on peut donner
qu'est le plus précieux et qui est
vraiment un objet que j'espère qu'on
arrivera à faire dans les quatre
prochaines années c'est on a un des
meilleurs systèmes éducatifs au monde on
a le meilleur système éducatif
francophone au monde sa personne ne
pourra nous ne jamais nous l'enlever il
faut qu'on vende le plus disponible
possible nos contenus de pédagogie du
plus jeune âge jusqu'au supérieur et ça
ça bénéficiera massivement à tous les
centres de formation les écoles les
universités africaines et à tous les
étudiants qui voudront à prendre seul
des choses en francophonie on a
construit comme une force elle est née
dans l'histoire dans des contextes
différents nous jouer c'est devenu une
force positive il faut que nous on
injecte 2 dans tout ce qui peut
permettre un plus grand appétit je vais
regarder l'équipe vous avez des
questions dégâts
oui
j'avais l'air gêné non c'est un génie
c'est que bon le des codecs sont en
pense quoi c'est à dire c'est à dire ce
que vous voulez que je vous dise
le une petite poignée
patenté chargée de valider ou
d'invalider des informations de deux
mètres en orange ou en rouge des choses
qu'est ce que vous en pensez le fait que
ce soit détenu pas part à quelque chose
de plus collégiale je peux pas vous
répondre je n'ai pas d'avis particulier
je vais vous dire les questions où les
dernières
milliard mahjoubi eux merci on vous les
conseillez notre communauté d'aller
regarder la séance de ces la commission
aux affaires économiques du 25 octobre
et votre audition au sénat même genre
qui avaient eux mêmes joueurs on a eu
beaucoup de boulot pour vous suivre on
va dire que payer des impôts pour payer
votre salaire nous avons prouvé ça vous
avez bien pas franchement on n'est pas
d'accord sur tout mais pour être trivial
et un peu vulgaire vous sortez bien les
doigts du cul sur ce sujet là et c c'est
appréciable et on pourra débattre autant
que vous voudrez mais au moins vous
voyez qu on débattra au plus profond de
la spécificité mieux et on voulait
remercier votre ancien chef de cabinet
qui est formidable qui nous qui nous a
été absolument qui a été absolument dans
un professionnel avec nous qui nous a
suivis depuis qu'on s'est rencontré la
nuit du hack leïla qui nous a appelé une
fois par semaine souvent très tard qui
ne se déconnecte ne jamais d'ailleurs
qui ne s'était déconnecté jamais
on pourra parler une prochaine fois la
collection lâcher des salaires tu moshé
les salariés merci beaucoup et merci de
faire preuve d'ouverture direct cash
sans chichi on voulait vous là aussi
parce que sur d'autres ministères c'est
beaucoup plus complexe beaucoup plus
lent beaucoup plus archaïques et celle
où ça se passe simplement et ben
bienvenue et puis à bientôt à bientôt
mercerat
[Musique]
holmes